today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by bio search technologies hello
everyone and welcome to the coronavirus
webinar series produced by laberd's
today's webinar title is rapid response
to the corona virus outbreak how
collaboration meets the challenge
hi I'm Xavier Gutierrez of lab routes
and I'll be your moderator for today's
event
before we begin I would like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you
would like during the presentation to do
so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send well answer
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen and as a reminder this
presentation is educational and offers
free continuing education credits click
on the continuing education credits tab
located in the top right corner of the
presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credit
I now present today's speaker dr. Gertz
Koon dr. Kunak holds a PhD in immuno
oncology from Utrecht University and the
Netherlands and has been active in the
molecular diagnostics industry for over
15 years in various global roles
he joined LGC bio search technology one
and a half years ago and oversees the
strategic development for the molecular
diagnostic segment for a complete
biography on our speaker please visit
the biography tab at the top of your
screen dr. Cooney
you may now begin your presentation
thank you so much for the introduction
well covered 19 is tightening its grip
on the world the woj general director
has purged countries to test in order to
control the infection rate and flappy
the curve this January this year many
research organizations and insecure
diagnostic manufacturers have been
scrambling to identify the corona virus
sequence and design diagnostic protocols
and tests
although the IVD industry is actively
scaling up production to meet the sharp
rise in demand fastening is still
limited no single organization is able
to form a beachhead against Corbett 90
rather it takes the collaboration within
and across industries as well as
countries to fight this pandemic
component supplier LTC biases
Technologies plays a key role in
supporting RVD manufacturers and
clinical labs in this ongoing battle
against coronavirus this webinar will
give you insight in our activities and
capabilities
by such technologies as a comprehensive
genomics portfolio from LGC providing
products and services for genomic
analysis that support mission critical
application in molecular diagnostics
port of customers from assay development
to commercialization for expertise in
sample preparation Holger sentences and
components for pcr an idea
providing consistent quality and scale
up we enable across the most seamless
and fast time to market delivering
success at full scale from the start
as a true partner we understand the
needs of our customers along the
complete product development pipeline
and the lever solutions facilitating
consistent quality at any scale to our
CGP manufacturing and I was a 13485
compliant facilities we deliver
vertically integrated raw material
sourcing for critical components and
showing global supply chain continuity
portfolio office of the shell customize
and OEM products such as ru and GMP old
goals including the HQ probes
high-performance PCR enzymes Parsifal
enzymes and master mixes
NGH reagents nucleic acid components for
DNA and RNA synthesis sample preparation
and purification chemistry as well as
instrumentation
a reason genome web webinars with Co
Diagnostics provide a good example of
how we collaborate what our customers
apply our capabilities and expertise to
enable our customers to reach their
goals thanks to the solid partnership we
have built with Co Diagnostics we
understand their processes have short
communication lines and can support
their myths accurately and internally
manner this is important for first-time
to market but even more crucial when
responding to an outbreak so just go
with 19
having the capability to fast-track
production scale-up
while maintaining consistent quality and
supplier security is pivotal in these
times
RTC bias which technologies has a strong
track record in responding to outbreaks
working closely with the CDC and
molecular diagnostics manufacturers
providing components for molecular
diagnostic tests but also valuable
reiations for swine flu avian influenza
A and seasonal influenza
learn from previous outbreaks and can
see what the current coronavirus
pandemic the need for diagnostic tests
increases rapidly to meet demand
manufacturers and suppliers are required
to quickly adapt and scale up production
of these cash
with over 35 years experience inaudible
manufacturing and a vertically
integrated raw material sourcing we are
optimally equipped to scale up
production and need sharp increases in
the mark our customers such as Public
Health laboratories value death after
the name of them to meet their goals
since the beginning of this year we've
mobilized resources and expertise to
deliver Rapid Response to cope with 94
customers in public health and private
sector
we have been expediting all those with
bhq technology for piranha virus testing
producing cbc qualified lots of 290 and
cough CDC problem for our market and are
currently working on making all the
balls and crepes for other protocols
available
we recently launched Sarah cares equipex
call of our resource of to reference
material and our actively testing new
rt-pcr and raw mixes such as epi script
and a highly thermostable rapid-fire
as we have in expediting all of our
manufacturing for coronavirus testing or
portfolio fluor force and quenchers
including our packet of bhq technology
form the backbone of many molecular
diagnostic tests with a broad range of
dyes and highly efficient black hole
quenching technology we offer open
platform solutions for targeted qPCR
suitable for multiplexing with minimal
crosstalk
our range of these new probes these Q
[ __ ] q + + v skim nova allows for
flexibility and probe design based on
the needs of your application
well obviously folks offer a
cost-effective approach solution which
q+ delivers superior mismatch
discrimination and pH Canova and arms
detection through optimal crunchy
as a need for testing is increasing we
offer CDC qualified locks of 2019 ankles
CDC program farmer kids leaving on or 35
plus years of all you experience
vertically-integrated raw material
sourcing and multiple manufacturing
sites in the USA Annamayya we can ensure
supply quality and security while
addressing flexibility in the mark
our operation process allows for timing
and consistent upscaling capabilities
delivering 1 million tests per week with
capacity to increase
let's Erica being part of the LGC group
since end of 2018 we offer the ActiveX
technology which enables full process
control solutions to process controls
mimic clinical samples far better than
plasmids or naked in our DNA or RNA as
they must go through the extraction step
to accept nucleic acids for
amplification and they are highly stable
the recombinant offer virus is
genetically engineered to not replicate
and it is heat treated it's therefore
non-infectious and saving use as well as
the solution
this technology delivers more consistent
controls than inactivated virus and it's
customizable to sequences of interest
the accuflex technology was used to
develop a recently owns a duplex source
code to product
the echo plaque source of two offers
known infections and replication the
session control enabling safe handling
who process control but real viral
protein code it is compatible with
essays targeting CDC and whu-oh
sequences as depicted in the current
table
also includes negative reference
material it has long-term stability at
pragmatic temperatures that no freeze
solving required and it is easy to adapt
to unique affiliations or potential new
strain
the Echoplex our scope to reference
material kit comes with voice kryos
positives and five vowels and negatives
of 1.5 millimeter each at five thousand
copies per ml
with a recommended storage temperature
between 2 and 8 degrees Celsius North
pre sewing is required
providing ease of use protein
applications
utilizing or program primary kit as well
as or accuflex reference material for
source of to we are actively testing or
reverse transcriptase rapid-fire
and epic ripped for one-step RT qPCR
detection of source code to preliminary
results look very promising and further
details on this will fall soon
for many weeks now the scientific
community industry and healthcare are in
over drawings to enable actual
diagnostic testing for SARS costume as
emphasized by the WH o general director
to test this is of crucial importance to
flatten the curve of infection however
both industry has been scaling up
production demand is still outstripping
supply
see boys search technologies continues
to ramp up its activities in the fight
against this pandemic when looking for a
component supplier we recommend you
remain selective and choose a supplier
the truly works together with you it is
key to ensure there is a thorough
understanding of your current needs and
processes as well as long-term ambitions
for maintaining supply quality and
security
identify how your supplier sources its
raw materials and how it provides
redundancy in manufacturing make sure
the supplier is flexible and can be
change in amount to timely and
consistent upscaling capabilities
overall it's key to build a good
partnership and short communication
lines
recommend downloading the whitepaper six
tips for early stage MDX companies
seeking successful commercialization
even if you're working in a clinical lab
corrections in the point against
coronavirus we are stronger together all
collaboration with Co Diagnostics is a
clear example of this I invite you to
reach out to us and explore how we can
support you meeting your needs
thank you all for attending stay safe
and the floor is now open for questions
you
for that informative presentation we
will not start the Q&A portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen now let's get
started our first question is how can
you support State Public Health labs who
are working to develop their own
laboratory-developed tests
yeah that's a great question and we are
providing a range of solutions that can
be utilized by public health labs to
develop their own ldt from custom old
Eagles rt-pcr enzymes at describing
rapid fire to BCC qualified Lots to just
discuss in the presentation as well as
the accuflex carnivore with reference
material considering the FDA's recently
released policy guidance high complexity
CLIA labs are permitted to begin using
terms and patient samples as soon as
they are validated eternally provided
they have notified the FDA and
subsequently fall aua application within
15 days this is also known as policy a
policy B enables US states to authorize
steps within their jurisdictions that
will be run in high complexity CLIA labs
that's covered by policy D can be used
on patients as soon as they are
validated and the FDA is notified a
subsequent eua is not required in this
case up to today for state Washington
Nevada New York and Maryland have
notified FDA order intend to pursue this
pathway for detailed and up-to-date
information I recommend consulting the
FDA's website
our second question here is how can your
products support the ramp up and cope in
19 testing yeah thank you for that
question
we are a critical component supplier
from many of the top MDX manufacturers
and are really set up for high scale
production moreover we are actively
testing or individual components in
order to provide a complete solution for
molecular testing of coronavirus besides
servicing osed manufacturers
this will allow labs to develop a use
lab develop tests which components for
which supply is secured
all right and we'll be wrapping up with
this final question how do you ensure
supply security with increasing demand
another great question and not only are
we set up for high scale production but
or vertically integrated raw material
sourcing we also have full control over
all raw materials and ask multiple
production sites in both the USA as well
as Europe which really enables us to
secure supply 205 partnerships with
customers we are well informed on the
processes and have short communication
lines and that really enables us to have
efficient collaboration and all they're
taken into account really helps us to
ensure supply security
well thank you again dr. Cunha for your
time today and your important research
before we go I'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting question questions we
did not have time for today and those
submitted during the on demand period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration this webcast can be
viewed on-demand through the end of 2020
lab roots will alert you via email when
it's available for replay and we
encourage you to share that you know
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event until next time
goodbye